thank you everyone welcome to our
expert briefings series uh i'm conrad uh
one of the co-chairs of pi data global
2021
uh we're very happy today to uh have
uh
a great panel to come talk to us about
how you can benefit by contributing to
open source uh we have
leah the executive director of nonfocus
katrina director of nonfocus james the
director of num focus
and ian who's a long time non-focused pi
data
collaboration
operator and uh
yeah co-founder of pacific 11.
so
please if you guys would like to
kick it off
so i think maybe a good way to start
would be to have our panel contributors
just briefly introduce themselves uh
what their relationship with num focus
is and since this is an expert briefing
perhaps some of the expertise that they
may bring to this session
from there i'll hand it over to ian who
will lay out a couple of the questions
which i think that we wanted to go
through and at the same time we'll open
it up to the audience for the audience's
questions
given the audience that i see will hold
off on asking
the participants in this session to
introduce themselves but if you want to
ask a question as part of your question
would be very helpful to know a little
bit more about you and so if you can
wait to introduce yourself
until that so i'll start with myself
then we'll go to katrina then ian and
leah for the
panel introductions my name is james
powell i serve as the chair of the
non-focus board of directors i've sat in
this role for three years and so some of
the expertise that i bring is in terms
of understanding how num focus works
from the board level
i've also served as vice president of pi
data for i think six or seven years now
and so i can talk a little bit to how pi
data as a community effort integrates
with the open source community as a
whole and focuses goals
and finally for work i do a lot of
corporate training on open source tools
and so i can speak a little bit to how
organizations think about open source
from the perspective of integrating it
further into their work
katrina
yes hi my name is katrina real
i've been on the board of directors for
num focus for the last three years up
until recently i was the treasurer of
num focus
i recently stepped into the president
position so i'm very happy to talk about
any of the
issues coming up in num focus
as far as
my history with pi data i've been a long
time open source contributor a long time
ago before i moved into more of a
community organizer and fundraising
position
for my day job i am director of data
science at cloudflare um i run a small
team over there and uh i can also speak
about uh corporate responsibility as
well as participation in open source
communities from a corporate perspective
thank you katrina so hello everyone my
name is ian osfold i ran one of the
expert briefings earlier today on high
performance python um for this setting
uh i've been involved in pi data for
over eight years now um i'm one of the
co-founders of pi data london which is
one of the largest i think the largest
uh pi data community on the planet
and with our 11 000 members at least
free pandemic when we could meet up
every month with a couple of hundred
people turning up um and our annual
conference which would contribute
funding uh to numb focus which uh leah
can touch on shortly i think um and uh
in my professional career
i work with companies on a strategic
basis helping teams deliver things of
value which includes the question of hey
how do we use open source to most effect
and why should we get involved in the
open source community and i teach and
during teaching i try to remind all of
my students particularly people in
financial services hey you're using
software from the open source community
rather than just consume it's nice to
contribute back and here are some
arguments as to why you might want to
get involved and often i'm met with
blank faces people not realizing that
this is a community they can get
involved with rather than just consuming
from and so i'm looking forward to
getting a bit of discussion here for
those of you who want to get involved
individually um or also get involved
professionally with your company and
help take the company on that journey
that's me over to you leah
thanks ian
my name is leah silent i'm the
miss conrad said executive director of
no focus
i have been with num focus
from its beginning in early 2012
and
have helped with
various boards
as the boards have
changed throughout the years to be able
to
implement our programs our fiscal
sponsorship program which we now have 45
projects our educational
initiatives which include our events
our
diversity equity and inclusion
initiatives as well and just working
with projects working with their user
communities both
on academic research and
enterprise levels as well
thank you leah um so uh james do you
want to step in
no please please ian i know you had some
initial questions to get started for
those of you who just joined us in this
session this is an open session with
some of your questions ian's going to
just kick things off with a couple of
planted questions
if you want to jump on audio and jump on
video and ask a question or engage in
the discussion feel free to do that
as part of that if you could just let us
know what your name is and give us just
a very brief bio so we can understand
the perspective that you're bringing as
part of your question but let's get
things started with ian ian you had some
initial questions
thanks james so
for leah and katrina
a lot of people attending the pie data
conferences over the years turn up for
the conference they get to hear great
talks they get to meet uh people who are
passionate about their work and they
know they're involved in the community
and then there's this pie data thing
that wraps it all up and it's an
unfocused thing but a stand that's uh
that's present
but many people don't know about the num
focused relationship to pi data where
the money goes why there is money uh in
this ecosystem behind open source
because hey everyone works for free in
their evenings and uh surely it's all
done unpaid um and many people are just
ignorant about the financial side of the
legal side of this um could one of you
say a couple of words around the
relationship between pi data numb focus
and the financial support around open
source uh just to set the scene
i think leah and i can answer that
question pi data i believe started off
uh with two goals one to help foster a
community of users and two to serve as a
fundraising for num focus um leah can
speak a little bit more to what
nonprofit finances look like but
generally there's an idea of restricted
versus unrestricted finances money which
is dedicated to a particular purpose
like particular changes to projects or
money which can be used across projects
for open purposes
pi data serves as one of the larger
sources of open
unrestricted financing and so it's pi
data which goes to supporting a lot of
the efforts that are not specifically
related to one development goal for one
specific project but across many
different projects across the ecosystem
and leah if you want to add some
sure yeah i think it's important for
those who are involved in pi data and pi
data events and you
purchase tickets to those events to know
that that support is going directly to
help them focus continue to provide
critical services to projects that
we work with projects to make sure they
have funding coming in from
additional sources then focus does not
fund all the projects but what we do is
make sure that when projects skip
funding that funding is able to be
allocated where it needs to go to pay
for development time to pay for
operational support and the
infrastructure that these projects have
to have if they get a large grant they
have to have foundational support
to be able to
manage that grant and that is the work
we do and i can talk more about that and
go into detail the cost of providing
that but it's not um it's not
insignificant and so numb focus um
almost 90 of all of our costs are put
back in programming for projects
and making sure that um the projects
that we all know use and love are
sustainable
and i think katrina you can also speak
to a stat that we've batted around in
the board which is that
for a very large grant the
administration costs for that grant are
often greater than what we can take from
the grant itself and so things like pi
data help to support our administration
of other monies that come in through
done focus katrina yeah absolutely the
administrative costs for sure are much
lower when they're coming through the
num focus organization if any of y'all
have ever worked with academic
organizations or some other you know
grant uh handlers basically sometimes
they can take upwards of 50 percent of
the money that's coming in um as leah
just mentioned you know 90 of our our
funds are coming straight into the
project so we're taking
a much smaller cut first off and then
second off um like i said you know we
were talking about the earmarked funds
are going straight to projects being
able to go straight into you know that
ecosystem but then the unrestricted
funds help us you know start um support
newer projects we are able to give small
development grants out to smaller
projects and also help them grow
and then on top of that i just want to
mention that
you know
the pi data events for sure help
subsidize this con this this cost right
so there truly is a um
a commitment to making sure that the
projects are well funded um the the pi
data events for sure all of the money
that's coming in you know we take a very
small cost
provide really good content and then use
that money in order to subsidize all of
these financial initiatives for the
organization and the projects associated
with them
okay thank you thank you so thank you to
all of you
well certainly yes thanks for everyone
who pays for a ticket and donates uh in
any form and because the financial
supports
should make clear
is much more efficiently served back to
the underlying projects
and the bit that's often not talked
about is uh the alternative is hey
nobody takes any cuts and the open
source maintainers take the money
themselves um but then of course they've
got to spend late nights doing the
accounting and running the legal side
and the accounting side which is no fun
typically you do that outside of your
paid employment
and that takes a lot of time and
responsibility to get right so
um of course we need bodies like numb
focus who administer this and take away
some of these pains and provide um some
things like a legal representation for
trademarks and brands and protection and
guidance and the same as we get with the
python software foundation ian if i may
talk on one small item that you
mentioned
a non-profit is not about
excusing yourself from anything that is
commercial excusing yourself from
anything that is monetary or financially
related it's about changing the goal the
end goal of
what this is all about whether it is
about creating profit for shareholders
as part of some capitalist system or
whether it's about benefiting a
particular cause and so there is quite a
bit of money involved in an organization
like num focus
people still have to eat people still
need to pay their rent but one of the
things that distinguishes it as a
community driven foundation is this
money goes to serve the underlying goal
of open source scientific computing
software
and to do this in a fashion that
benefits the broad public as a whole and
so the direction of the projects and the
open governance of the projects is a
critical portion of this
panda's goal is not to make any one
organization successful its goal is to
provide a high quality tool for any
organization for a core set of users and
so unlike say open source that comes out
of a corporate
uh organization where they're doing that
as a benefit to the world to see the
code maybe interact with it they're
missing the governance part where the
long-term sustainability long-term
direction that the code takes
is one that is still for the benefit of
the organization as opposed to one
that's for the benefit of the end users
of that tool
thank you james
i've opened up in the chat window um i
just made a note that uh you're welcome
to ask questions next if you've got
thoughts around what we're discussing
and you just want to post them in the
chat window please do that um or you can
use the uh the reactions button in zoom
control to raise your hand and then
we can take a question that way um if
that helps um i know one thing that
comes up um and i don't know which if
you would like to field it um is the
question of hey if i if i give money as
a company if i donate some money or i
become a longer term contributor um to
numb focus what do i get what's the
point in doing that um so what is the
high level pitch behind that
katrina maybe you might speak to this
sure i wasn't sure who wanted to pump it
too yeah i wasn't wrong
yeah absolutely so i mean obviously
corporations are not necessarily going
to do um you know to give money with
nothing in return right it's not out of
the goodness of their heart that
generally they give out money um but for
sure i think that there are a lot of
different um you know advantages to
adoption of open source and also then
giving back to the open source community
right um so first off the idea that
you're getting um
by using open source software there's
generally more adoption across other
organizations right so you're able to
take part in hiring and obtain retaining
head talent that has all of these skills
that are able to be transferred into
your company first off right
second off you have sort of an industry
standard that you're dealing with that
is very easy for you to be able to
contribute back to
the idea that if you do get involved and
you support your developers being able
to contribute to that that you are part
of the conversation
especially in tools that are have wide
adoption
on top of that i think that it's really
important for us to talk about the
infrastructure aspect of open source a
lot of the projects that are in the pi
data ecosystem um for example numpy you
know is a fundamental project that you
know hundreds and hundreds of other
projects have spawned out of right i
don't think it's necessarily
it's not advantageous for us to let this
project fail right so making sure that
we have the governance that we have the
support that we have the financial
support in order to keep projects like
this going are
incredibly important to the success of
your business on top of it right it's
not just a matter of being able to say
hey we're doing this really good thing
for the community there is a very real
financial incentive um for being able to
attract retain talent and then also be
in the situation where you are
contributing to that infrastructure that
will create more sustainability within
your own organization as well and so i
think that there are other points that
we can actually bring to the table here
but um you know
i don't think that we can keep thinking
of the open source community especially
not in this area which has gotten so
much adoption as just being these
projects that are out there they're part
of a much larger infrastructure that if
it fails we all kind of fail together
there are too many organizations that
reliant on the on to these projects for
us to allow them to fail and that's why
i think that it's advantageous for them
to keep giving and participate in the
community
james how do you feel that question oh
sorry leah please no that's okay i was
just i was just gonna add that we you
know you can easily go to our website
and look up all the benefits of being a
corporate sponsor but one that i did
definitely want to highlight is
that for our golden platinum corporate
sponsors they also get to participate in
the dem focus advisory council and
that's a very important group to us to
provide support in the way of advice and
insight and suggestions as a user on a
on a corporate level so i think that
involvement in that
you know sitting at a table of um
other
colleagues and folks in the community
that are also sponsoring them focus
are
we have actually still some of our
founding board members on that council
and it provides a way to have a level of
insight into them focus
into the services that we're providing
for the projects but also in
just how that service is provided how it
may be able to be improved and
delivered more efficiently so it's a
great great way to get involved
perhaps leah to add on to that we can
talk about one specific corporate
sponsor
two sigma is an organization in the
financial industry and many
organizations in the financial district
view open source as just a vendor they
don't have to pay they get the source
code for free but there's no checks that
have to be written in order to do that
and they are organizations that
oftentimes interact with vendors and so
they just see this as you know free
software in one sense of the term
whereas an organization like two sigma
which is one of our corporate sponsors
that sits on the advisory board
understands that
the enormous amount of human effort that
goes into creating tools like jupiter
numpy and pandas has saved that company
enormous amounts of money from building
those tools themselves but the long-term
sustainability of those tools requires
giving back in one form or the other not
necessarily just giving back money but
also participating in the governance the
evolution the long-term development of
these tools so two sigma is a company
where we have a number of core
developers
who both work for the company and are
given just a little bit of their time as
part of their main work to contribute
back to the projects in the form of
source code contributions
an organization that has even lent staff
for certain
administration and logistic functions to
numb focus in order to help them focus
better modernize some of its systems an
organization that has had its staff help
out with events just like pi data global
and to help run these fundraising events
as part of their main duties and it is
the case that and i don't want to say
any names but
there was one num focused staff member
who
actually there were two non-focused
staff members sorry two two sigma staff
members who were part of the creation of
this very event paid to global last year
they were integral to the construction
of a brand new event in a very uncertain
time for num focus they were allowed to
take their work time in order to help
move the and to help support the open
source community and i understand that
as part of their own internal promotion
process their contributions of this
nature to open source were considered as
part of their year-end review and so
it's an organization that's really
internalized the idea of it's not just a
vendor i don't have to pay but part of a
larger
industry-wide movement that i am
participating in
i just want to add on to that that i
think there's also something that people
need to take into consideration is the
idea of when a package that you have
reliance on and that's part of your code
base doesn't make it right
and you have all of these dependencies
that are you know are all stemming from
this particular package that you've now
incorporated into your ecosystem
um once again if there's no
sustainability there's no governance
there's no
continuity as the project matures
there's a huge cost in replacing that as
either being able to you know come in
and
you know there's an opportunity cost as
well as just the cost of development in
order to move around this and once again
a lot of these packages have become
industry standard so they're not the
kinds of things that are there's no
you can't avoid paying that cost at some
point
if you do
if you fail to to to maintain it
very good points uh so we've spent uh 15
20 minutes talking uh amongst the board
here it's probably time to open up to
some questions uh and observations from
others a few on the on the call here um
i've posted a couple of questions in the
chat uh and james just made some points
uh please feel free to use the chat and
what will be useful in the chat is just
to see which kind of companies or
geographies are represented uh by you
here if you can make a note in the chat
that will be good and what i'm really
after right now um is some uh feedback
from you why are you on the call what do
you want to learn um we can certainly
dig some more into personal contribution
into open source and why that might
benefit me the individual
me the corporate
um but uh maybe you're here for other
reasons um so we should dig into that
and see uh which kind of questions need
to be addressed and so uh for those of
you there's a i know easily half of you
on the call i don't recognize your names
um
what are you doing here um what are you
looking uh to get out of this session
uh yeah just to get uh get things
started um
i wanted to talk a little bit about uh
from a corporate perspective uh you know
like how contributing helps them
um just uh so so other than being the uh
co-chair for pi data global this year
i'm also a partner python anywhere
and and one of the things we found very
useful
in you know establishing
uh
by contributing and establishing sort of
like open connections and relationships
with uh
uh with different open source projects
is that not only is it sort of like uh
hey like if if if you start like
delving into this library and like like
you want somebody to talk to you know
who to talk to but also you know if even
if like there's a certain feature that
that's missing and you guys and you
desperately need it then it's it's it's
pretty useful to be able to know
somebody there and say hey like i get
the convo started on you know can we set
up like a specific
funding thing or grant thing to get this
feature developed
conor do you have any examples of those
kind of features maybe jupiter hub
editions psychic learn models
uh so
not in the focus ecosystem because we're
pathetic where we're doing a lot more
sort of server-side stuff
so i guess
specifically
we've done something like this with
nginx before
uh and i'll just actually
jump off that point um with our um
hosting for pi data london meetups by
the man group uh in london's in central
london uh hedge fund
large hedge fund
donating space uh over several years for
200 people every month attending there's
quite a cost behind that um and i asked
the cto at one point um hey you know how
many people have you hired from our
ecosystem well actually and it's none i
said oh crikey that's uh that's that's a
very small number um why do you host us
he said oh well because the second order
effect of hosting an event like this and
open sourcing some of our core
technologies that's their um time series
time tick database
arctic
is that quants and data engineers who
wouldn't normally come to us come to us
because they like our open nature
it turns out some quantum some data
engineers want to work with a more open
facing
company rather than a closed financial
services organization so they found a
recruitment benefit as a second order
benefit from hosting us um and that
meant that they were happy to host us
for years and they will post pandemic be
continuing uh to be happy to host us um
and so some of these soft benefits are
hard to quantify um but they're clearly
very powerful that's a lot of investment
that we get from the man group directed
our way
which uh yes you can't put point a
single person they hired but nonetheless
they're happy to keep on offering us
that kind of support
i'm curious ian and katrina do you ever
find that organizations
see themselves either at the forefront
of the industry
changing how the industry moves or being
just responsive to how the industry has
already moved and as a consequence
participation in the open source
community really does dictate whether
they're a follower or they're leading
the pack whether they're the ones who
are at the whims of potentially even
their competitors or whether the ones
who are setting the tone for
you know the industry as a whole
katrina
sure i mean there are actually several
points that i can
address in this area right is the idea
that um of course some people really
want to have a seat at the table right
they they're able to help direct where
things are going understand what's going
on there provide la thought leadership
and put themselves out as being the
industry standard they're part of the
conversation and kind of move in that
direction but i also think that there is
the um
the added benefit and this is something
that i've talked with our own hr
department so the idea that workers want
to be on the forefront of technology
right
people actually leave jobs when they
feel like they're not learning new
skills or they're not moving forward in
their careers
if they feel like they're stagnant if
they're working with old technologies if
they're not on the forefront of what's
happening they start to feel like they
are becoming irrelevant and they will
jump they'll move to another company
they will not stay there that things do
have to move forward in order to be able
to do that and the cost of attrition for
sure is one of the biggest costs that's
always come up on my team the idea that
a
worker is really not going to be a
profit center for two years until
they're on your team takes that long in
order for people to get settled to be
able to move their project to be able to
put things into production and deploy
and all of those areas around that
then you also have the cost of handing
it off even after two years that they've
become a profit center right so having
people that are happy workers that feel
like they're continuing to learn and
grow
is a really big benefit and i do also
want to mention that by having workers
contribute to open source projects
they're able to get that immediate
feedback from really really experienced
developers to tell them what they're
doing right and what they're doing wrong
i always joke with people that when i
was in graduate school i didn't learn
how to code in any of my classes i
learned how to code because i
contributed to open source and i had
some of the most
frank and talented
developers giving me feedback real time
on all of my um well back then it was
not pull requests but you know what i
mean and um
so having that available is also
providing that you know one-upmanship in
your own organization the quality of
your code is going to get better because
you're receiving mentorship there's a
trade-off there and that mentorship may
not be available or that thought
leadership may not be available within
your organization so moving out into the
community and helping it move forward is
definitely a big win i think for
corporations
i was gonna say from like a like
individual perspective like advancing
your career and from like a corporate
hiring perspective it is so great to see
people
being like significant open source
contributors uh like like such an easy
test for whether
uh you know they know what they're
talking about and what they're doing
uh or not
um
interestingly for uh i've actually been
working with some python ghana people
and pi data ghana people i've been
running some high data workshops there
and we've been thinking about
uh you know how to incorporate sort of
open source contribution type stuff into
a
career certification thing and then uh
then you know some of the
different projects that i'm involved in
could just darkly hire from you know
like oh you're certified at this level
and so and so
to make the hiring process much easier
katrina i'm going to push back against
one of your arguments about making your
uh your employees happier um because if
your employees are happier and they're
contributing then they're visible they
can be poached and nobody wants them to
be poached so we should put them in a
corner and keep the lights off uh so
that no one can see this talent that's
otherwise shining in the corner and of
course it's a stupid argument so it's a
very bad argument if someone wants to be
focused they're going to go and talk to
a recruiter anyway um but some
narrow-minded uh managers will see the
negative and not see the positive uh
when i'm working uh at a strategic level
with teams um i will certainly have a
discussion um
with a manager who may say uh so uh ian
what kind of training could you bring in
what kind of training should we bring in
uh to skill the team up in new processes
and techniques well we can do a review
but also you could contribute to an open
source project because if you go through
a brutal review are very polite and
friendly and supportive but nonetheless
very hardcore review
on a pull request you're going to learn
an awful lot about making sure your code
is formatted correctly or following
docstring conventions you can write in a
legible fashion and hold an argument
your code runs correctly and there's
nice evidence around all of this you've
written the unit test the unit test
works and then once you get past all of
that all of a sudden you can see that
you can help somebody else and then you
can articulate to them why these skills
are necessary and if you bring any of
that back into your team all of a sudden
you're skilling up the entire team
some enlightened managers will say
that's a brilliant idea this feels like
free education i can maybe encourage my
people to do this over the weekend
somebody could encourage them to do that
but maybe let them have a friday
afternoon to do this instead and then
share what they've learned
and keep that inside the organization
and then some of those will adopt that
and i see there there it works really
quite nicely um but then the cell has to
be hey go and get free education at some
other contributors expense um but do it
under company time um so it's it's still
uh it's not quite a balanced argument
but it's a much more balanced argument
than just take and never give anything
back because
yeah everyone yeah i guess i look at it
that you know people are going to jump
ship regardless right if if you're on a
project and you do get poached or how
you know most of people in my field are
being
they're
they're going to have recruiters after
them all the time anyway i can't tell
you the number of recruiters who
actually contact me on a daily basis but
if i'm in
an organization that i feel you know has
the same values as i do and is keeping
me happy and making it so that i'm
continuing to learn um having that known
versus the unknown is definitely a good
thing and then also i think that
i think people really underestimate how
um there are a lot of companies i think
that say that they're able to give time
to work on open source that don't
it's
having worked from a lot of
organizations that said that they're
very happy to support and then turns out
that there is no actual support
you know getting paid to do open source
is definitely something a lot of open
source developers are trying to do in
their careers and regardless of the
money regardless of the projects
regardless of the management structure
or titles they're going to be attracted
to that and so i think that it kind of
just depends where your values are and
what kind of organization really dives
with what you're looking for in your
life right but for sure people are going
to leave regardless we're looking at
about a two and a half year tenure at
most tech companies regardless of who
they are at this point and so i think
that we have to
be realistic about what is the tour of
duty somebody's going to do on your team
as opposed to what is the chance that
they're going to stay there until they
retire because that's probably not going
to happen and so
they're more likely i think to stay in
my opinion if they are given all of
these different opportunities in order
to grow
yeah i just wanted to add one thing to
ian you were talking about the knowledge
that's gained from allowing your
employees or your team to be able to
contribute to open source and the other
advantage to
to corporations that that are doing this
or either supporting open source is that
that knowledge can then be applied to
projects that um are incubated in a
corporate setting so if your company is
um you know has created their own open
source tool i think james you you
mentioned this
at the beginning but then being able to
apply that knowledge just you know
you've contributed to another project
and see those best practices and be able
to apply them and see how that um you
know that project that was incubated in
your company can then
can then grow and you know eventually
possibly move out as a community driven
project
one thing i'll add is
talking about this idea of giving people
an opportunity for growth
pi data has i think served this purpose
for a lot of people if you really think
about community organizing it's an
opportunity for you to take on a
leadership role a leadership role where
you have to be very good at making
people want to do the things that you
need them to do
where the stakes are actually a little
bit lower than say the the fate of a
company although the fate of a
conference are still pretty high stakes
but it's an opportunity for you to
precociously introduce yourself into
this idea of leadership before many
organizations might actually officially
promote you into that and i have found
that in many cases people who make good
community organizers who make good
community leaders then make good leaders
at their job and much of what they learn
from trying to work with volunteers can
be directly applicable to working with
their team members because as i said it
really is a lot about setting a vision
and getting people to want to do the
things that you need them to do
so i'd like to ask the wider question um
i'm going to ask a wider question around
how a viewer you want to call um how
have you found introducing
open source support um contributions
hiring via increased visibility from
open source uh collaboration how any of
these topics uh have impacted you
hopefully positively
and whilst i'm asking that also rahman
you've noted that you work with
governments in the u.s i wonder if you
have any particular points there around
governmental interactions and open
source
and enlightened less enlightened
viewpoints
and their likelihood to contribute to a
wider ecosystem as well is that
something you'd be happy to talk about
for a minute what other people think
about uh their um their possible
responses and trying to elicit some
responses from all of you here uh about
your open source journey in corporations
yeah gosh um
it feels very remote um
i you know i it's been i
always with my my public sector clients
i'm trying to
bring them up sort of toward more modern
uh more modern engineering practices but
i wish i could sort of say that i'm
pulling them toward wanting to
contribute to open source but um even
getting them to use things like github
or know what uh you know dependency
management is uh is sort of where the uh
where the the sort of boundary is uh and
so there's a little ways to go but
it would be great in five or ten years
to say that that that i'm i'm pulling
people into making pull requests to open
source projects but we're not there
okay fair enough certainly i know in the
um the uk government i've got
many colleagues in london working under
some of the data gov initiatives which
have strong at least open source buy-in
um i don't know how much contribution
occurs uh the other side of that um but
it's a nicely forward-thinking um part
of our government from a technology
viewpoint um
of course we've got our financial
services industry here in london which
is very strong
which increasingly has been not
certainly adopting python open source
and open source in general
due to reasons that james mentioned
but also beginning to increase their
visibility and contributing back because
they're seeing benefits of that one of
them being the hiring benefit and so
everyone else on the call um how many of
you have found benefits from um from
introducing these conversations in your
firm or how many of you have resisted
having these conversations because they
feel like difficult ones and what would
be super useful is if you could switch
on your cameras
it'll be really nice to see some of you
if that will be possible
if they are reluctant to switch on their
cameras can they answer just in the chat
and that's absolutely fine as well i'm
always always whenever i do remote
training reminding everyone please turn
on your cameras doing training to a
bunch of blank screens is really hard
work
i like to see smiling happy faces there
we go camilla hello there hello again
uh it's good to see you again
jim hello again there we go that's a bit
better
uh
would anyone have a
an observation about introducing open
source or a problem introducing open
source to share
i think there's one that katrina can
speak to specifically from her own
professional experience
when you're introducing open source into
any sort of government project people
are making a bet that the tool that
exists today will be there in 10 years
and if it's not they're going to have to
take responsibility for it and they've
just added one more thing to their
shoulders i know katrina you worked a
lot with memex with darpa with these
government contracts and not being part
of the story of something that you rely
on what does that mean
yeah absolutely so um just so to kind of
set the background my background i have
worked with the u.s navy with the nsa
and with darpa
like james has talked about and within
all these agencies there's for sure a
reluctance to rely on open source
depending on the movement of the code
right so if you have a code base that is
not likely to move they don't care
because we can do a security review of
the package and decide that it's a-okay
it's stable enough in order to make sure
that it goes through the government
acceptance testing and then it goes into
a release and then for example it stays
on a destroyer for the next 10 years and
nobody ever touches it if we do have to
upgrade though if we have to move
forward we have to see whether or not
that package is viable enough in order
for us to
continue development for example if the
new
ddgs come out right and we have new
destroyers that suddenly we have to
support we have to make sure that we can
take our old code code base and then be
able to use it in the new um hardware
basically and so we have a lot of
problems around this right because it's
not just the search security review it's
not just the government acceptance
testing it's also on top of that making
sure that we can justify doing this and
then on top of that i do want to mention
that there are some legal concerns that
are involved there as well um just
because
there is the possibility that um in this
you know i don't think this has been a
big problem or anything of um
either classified information or
proprietary information or you know
corporate secrets a lot of different
things could end up
slipping into open source projects and
so
information or code moving in either
direction is always something that
people do worry about right but i think
if you do have a security clearance it's
unlikely you're just going to say okay
i'm going to take this classified piece
of code and i'm just going to slip it
into this project because hey why not
right but i do think that
you know and it's also very unlikely i
think that
people are going to adopt this this um
this project and then find that somebody
acted in bad faith that there was some
sort of security hole that there was
some sort of you know spy software or
something that was put in there right um
so but these are questions that come up
so working with the different
organizations for sure can be a problem
and then also finding people who would
be able to do that upgrade is also a
problem so having people in the
community that can come in and have the
knowledge to be able to come in and make
those changes for them if they do decide
to upgrade or they do decide to move
forward on a new release
so there are a lot of considerations to
take into account there
the memex project under darpa for sure
was much more forward thinking the idea
there was in fact to open source all of
the tools that we were creating so that
there was no barrier to entry for law
enforcement agencies to be able to get
access to our human trafficking tracking
software and so the idea there was that
we did want to be out on the forefront
we did want to put new ideas out there
we did want to make sure that it was
going to be something that um
was new it was something that was no one
had ever seen before it was completely
different from the commercially
available software that was out there
and that's why it was funded by the
government right was so that they were
able to put that kind of software out
into um into the community so my team
was for sure involved in that in order
to help guide that open source journey
if you will for the idea of the
government or government agency actually
releasing open source software and what
that would mean and what it would look
like
was it about having somebody who they
could trust on the inside who can give
them some guidance into a universe
that's very different than their own
absolutely there's you know there's a
certain ethos there's a certain you know
there's licensing considerations there
are all you know all of these different
pieces that they don't understand or if
they take responsibility
for a package that they are putting out
into the ecosystem where do they put it
who hosts it who maintains it what is
the governance of that look like how do
we make sure that this is something that
is sustainable
it was a completely new world for them
so bringing in an open source team that
had a lot of experience all from the pi
data ecosystem i might not add everybody
is a contributor on projects
to be able to advise and move that
forward and package it and make sure
that these were available and widely
distributed
which they did get distributed all over
the world to law enforcement agencies
primarily um it was a um it was a very
different experience for them and for
sure there were a lot of questions there
was a lot of confusion and so um that
was a it was a really big
undertaking for them not to mention it
was something completely new you know
darpa is not generally
um
into sharing secrets they don't and it's
not something that they're you know it's
our advanced defense area where we're
trying to develop new things that you
know trying to get ahead in our r d
for everything that's on the horizon um
it would be
not advantageous to our government
security in order to release those
things prematurely so this was a very
very different world for them
okay thanks for sharing that um i like
the idea of a
governmental organization placing things
into the open source community to ensure
longevity um that's uh that's
very forward-thinking position um and
it's not so hard now to point to python
say look at something like the uh the
t.o.b language popularity index where
python recently jumped from number three
most popular language on the planet the
number one most popular language on the
planet and say look the language will be
around for a long time it's been here
for a long time it's got a lot of people
behind it it's not disappearing
so yeah that makes a lot of sense from
from a better open source
but it doesn't help us get uh more
companies to
contribute and support staff
contributing um i wonder uh sanket uh
and camilla uh as uh as chairs you are
both chairs right for a pilot to global
that is your role along with conrad uh
and one other um and you're representing
two different continents uh camilla
you're based in germany and sanchez or
india uh how are you finding um
how do you find in your commercial
organizations the relationship with open
source and say easing hiring
because you've shared some something
that you've collaborated in some way uh
there can be an argument it's easier to
hire the right kind of people and maybe
that's a good argument or an argument
that falls on deaf ears i'm curious what
have been your observations
um yeah i think uh i think i have an
example with me which i can share with
everyone here
so uh i think the story goes back to
2018 when i started working with the
government of india on a ballistics
project with forensics government so
just to let you know that indian
government is not too much into
technology this there are still some
offices in india which where they use
windows xp and windows 7. so they are
not technical technologically advanced
so i was basically chosen out of a
hackathon along with my team to develop
a project
which would basically match the bullets
that were recovered from the crime scene
and to check if the different bullets at
the different crime scene were fired
from the same firearm so basically every
bullet fired from a sims from a same
firearm
leave some scratches on the bullet and
the shell which are unique to every
firearm so that's basically conduct a
fingerprint like a human fingerprint
so
basically when i was you know
brought in for the project i saw the
environment over here over in the
forensics lab so everybody and ever so
basically there are different different
levels in forensics lab like audio
visual human dna and stuff like that and
they were all using proprietary software
for which they were paying like
thousands of like thousands of dollars
for a year for their license and all so
i was basically brought in to develop
the forensic software for bullet
matching using all the open source
software and tools
and uh like it took me two years along
with my team and we did it so that was
basically kind of setting an example
that stuff could be done using like good
stuff can be built using open source you
don't need to pay like thousands of
dollars to you know have uh
i don't know maybe good software so
yeah i think that was the story and
which kind of like sets like a
uh
example for the whole
uh like i'm i'm so i'm in i'm in delhi
which is like the capital state of india
which uh so everybody was really amazed
and you know when we pitched the
software to the director of the lab they
were like really impressed that we did
all this without uh without spending any
money from their uh whole
the
whole fund which they received from the
central government
so
yeah i think that was that was my
take on the ian's question
thank you very much
um
okay so we're nearing the end of the uh
the discussion time that we have here um
uh do we have any other questions that
ought to be addressed uh from people in
the audience and it could be a question
or an observation or you might be
curious about ways that you could try to
get your
company uh your team to sign off on
contributing back which could be
person power
that could be sponsoring a conference it
could be giving support to non-focus or
it could be something else but if we've
got any of those questions now is
absolutely the right time to flush those
out so i'm just going to pause for a
minute and see if anyone has any of
those questions
uh and if we don't then maybe uh
lee and james will be time to summarize
ways that companies can get involved
just to see some of that thinking
for next week's conference
so does anyone have any questions around
getting more involved um that we might
discuss now
one observation back when i worked in
corporate was this like the sort of like
open bureaucratic hostility the entire
idea was just like constantly there i
mean you'd have these stories of people
trying trying their best to do it and it
revolved into some like ethics
investigation and then that was like
totally pointless and then they would
leave to another company that happened
with my friends um when they just tried
to do anything out in the open because
it's the culture is so built around
proprietary
that it's like almost unthinkable to
imagine doing something like
making a git commit with your corporate
email address right um
so i don't know what to do about that so
i just quit my day job and sort of
decided to make my living the hard way
that was my solution but um i i don't
know but that wasn't completely my
experience of the large private sector
uh when it comes to open source
right so i take i mean i totally hear
you on that and i've had a number of
these conversations with my clients and
the number of times a boss says it's
brilliant we're going to hire down the
line more efficiently if i let some of
our staff uh spend some time uh
committing to the open source community
it's a very small number of
conversations that have worked my way
there i do keep trying i'm very very
optimistic um but it's it's difficult to
get sign off there and i take the
conversations the other way so on my
mailing list i've got a newsletter i
share my thoughts people ask me hey ian
you've got jobs on here how do i
increase my chance of getting a new job
i said well one of the things you can do
is contribute to open source because
when you then go and apply to a job
and you can show that i've made a
contribution which could be as simple as
i wrote a bug fix so i wrote a bug or a
bug fix or a doc string fix or even i
contributed some code of material value
to a project but any of those steps mean
that i can demonstrate that i can
communicate clearly i can have a
conversation i can put forward a decent
argument and i can get something shipped
and i can't do that with my work because
my work's all private but with a public
contribution which i could do in my
spare time or maybe i could do under the
radar in the office because maybe if i'm
giving a bug fix for a project on a dock
string legal aren't going to care no
one's actually going to care i could
just do it in the office and taking a
better to ask forgiveness and permission
viewpoint on something that's totally
not connected with the organizations
there's no reason why anyone would
actually push back and hey if you're
looking for a job maybe you should just
crack on and do this anyway and and so
enlightened individuals will take that
argument and then begin to make some
contributions back um and possibly
they're contributing to a project and
i'll point people this way contribute to
a project where one of the lead
developers is in the company that you're
interested in because all of a sudden
you can just avoid hr in the recruitment
process at that point and have a very
sensible conversation with someone who
can see your work and cares about the
project and then you've got a one-on-one
conversation with someone who's got the
uh the ability to give the nod to you to
get you in for an interview so going
around that route can help and then that
benefits the companies that do support
the open source initiatives because they
get the nice candidates the smart
switched on uh motivated candidates
coming that way
it doesn't help
motivate the uh that the non-switched on
organizations except that they face the
continual drought of good talent uh and
at some point slowly the penny will drop
that they really should do something
about this and in the meantime the likes
of two sigma and other organizations
that fund pi data are very visible and
they get a great screaming pile of new
good talent coming at them because it's
a nice place to work it's a good
supportive uh clear good environment to
work in
so
that's the argument i always take i
don't i tried this with companies but
when that fails i just remind the
individuals hey it's in your best
interest to get some of these commits
out there uh it will serve you well in
the long term and that often motivates
people
ian i'm sure you've had this experience
and maybe you could share this with us
to help motivate the scale of
engagement
here's the scenario that i have seen
before
you're using some tool jupiter or
scikit-learn it's part of your core
business because it's part of your core
business when you run into a bug you
have no choice but to fix it
if that is a bug which is a very trivial
bug and it's a one-line change you might
go to github and you might submit a pull
request but if your engagement with the
open source community is limited to just
that one drive-by commit it can be very
hard for that to actually be accepted by
the core developers who might get to it
a week later who might get to it a month
later might be working on something else
that's a refactoring and the drive-by
commit just doesn't necessarily go
anywhere even if it's very small
as a consequence you start to
absorb responsibility that really
shouldn't be yours responsibility over
these core tools that you have to
maintain and you start to lose the
benefit of open source because you're
diverging from those code bases and even
if you had integrated with the open
source community in a very small way
just tell the project hey i'm a big
company and i use your project it would
make it easier when you have to have
those very small contributions to
actually integrate it into the process
to actually see that happen so that you
no longer are in this position where
you're absorbing responsibility over
time to satisfy your business use cases
but you're actually
having an open dialogue with the
projects to go back and forth you ever
seen that ian
i've certainly seen
companies
fork a copy of the code and edit it
locally
and then absorb it as another sunk cost
on the project
and i think the mistake there is to not
account for the fact that there is this
additional cost
as you say um on the project which
somebody has to support and there's a
dollar value you can put against that uh
as a bit of as a tax or some friction
against your team moving forwards and
the enlightened individuals in the
company will see that but the bosses
won't necessarily understand or care
about that
and part of the assumption will be hey
that bug gets fixed later we'll just
upgrade later on when it's been fixed by
somebody else and so i thought yeah
that's i see that um and i don't know
what the right argument to use there is
to convince anyone um
except to get the enlightened
individuals to uh not ask permission in
the first place uh and just to go and
find a nice bug report that happens to
contain a fix inside it um and then just
push it out there
which
that doesn't solve the uh the culture
problem in an organization but it does
at least ship some of those fixes so
that somebody else
can integrate them over time
anyone else seen any better examples of
that working actually motivating change
i was just going to say that actually in
one of the organizations that i did work
in we did have a no open source policy
you could in fact be let go from your
your um
your job if you were ever caught
um contributing to open source and i'm
not going to name the organization but
i'm also not going to say that i didn't
give patches to other people that may
have
contributed them on under their own
names but um i'm not suggesting you do
that because there was actually just
recently a court case around that which
was a little bit
scary but anyway what i did want to
mention is that this organization we ran
into exactly that problem the idea that
we had packages that were relatively new
that became dependencies in a rather
large code base that was a multi-million
dollar project and suddenly we were in
the position where what would happen we
would create bug fixes or we would put
new features in there and then we would
put them into an internal repository
within the company that was not shared
anywhere and we ran into the problem
very very quickly where we were out of
sync
with everything that was going on
absolutely everywhere i'll just put it
that way and there really was a
the cost of being able to
contribute that back is nothing right
however the cost of fixing this problem
was huge i mean just an unbelievably
huge problem and so um developer time
once again you know just the cost of
downtime the cost of you know bugs on
production systems all sorts of things
like that because
you know the skills that we're hiring
for within the team are not necessarily
the same skills as library developers
and so having people who are able to
maintain a library have never done it
before is
it's a bad idea i'll just put it that
way and so um for sure i've seen that
happen and so it quickly became very
apparent that we needed to have some
sort of open source policy there was
just no question about it whatsoever and
then i do want to mention also that like
it is from a leadership level i can tell
you that i have these conversations all
the time by the way where i'm talking to
leadership and a lot of times also i get
to be the decision maker so it's very
easy for me to say hey this is our
policy this is what we're going to do
and i can open it up and i can offer
people 20 time and all of these
different things in order to work on
open source not every organization is
going to be okay with that right and you
can give all of these different reasons
you can go on and on and on there's not
one organization that i've worked with
except for that one but you can't do it
in your own time but for sure it it
sometimes can be a very hard sell and
there's all of the problems with you
know the legality you know not wanting
to be associated with a project not
feeling like they have any
responsibility not opening the
floodgates that suddenly they make an
exception for this one bug fix and
suddenly they have this huge
tsunami of projects and responsibilities
that are suddenly on their shoulders um
frankly i think that's a kind of a crazy
idea that suddenly everyone would look
to you to be the developers for
everything
but um
at the same time you know
it depends and i think that this is part
of the thing that i really struggle with
as somebody who did go more in like the
corporate route at least for now is that
the idea that you want to be able to
effect change that's one of the reasons
i wanted to go into that kind of
leadership was that i could affect
change and be the decision maker in that
area
but then also running into roadblocks
there and i think it's important to have
more people in the community that are
moving in that direction to be quite
honest that demand that when they're
taking jobs if they have the skills and
they're the people that people want to
hire that you know that's part of the
deal that you bring in a leader that you
know is going to be
involved in this kind of community and
so um
you know infiltrating from within i
think is also a very good idea because
what i think ends up happening a lot of
times is that we have open source
developers that end up creating their
own consulting companies or they go off
and kind of do their own thing
and um and then it's harder
you know it's harder to affect that
change within an organization but it is
a balance and it's also kind of you know
how
how much can you take like how dogged
can you be
um and uh you know maintaining that
motivation to keep pushing for an agenda
and shall we move to our final thoughts
or final comments absolutely i think uh
yes james and leanny uh closing comments
about uh companies and individuals
getting involved in numb focus
so perhaps we can go and reverse order
liath and ian and katrina than myself
and then conor i can close us out
yeah be happy to go um
yeah so i would just like to invite
everyone to um
get involved i was just getting ready to
add a couple links in in the chat links
to pages on our website that give you
some more information on whether that is
um making a financial contribution
um encouraging your company to make a
financial contribution or become an
unfocused sponsor and if you want to do
that please reach out and we will help
you with those conversations but there
are also other ways to get involved num
focus is really increasing our community
involvement through several committees
and we've got
affiliated project selection committee
where we now have a community-led
committee that is helping
review applications for our affiliated
projects and
through small development grants and
our disk committee
is getting ready to open up nominations
for that involvement that's our
dei initiative so there's lots of ways
to get involved please
go to the website research or if you
want additional information or you're
not finding information um happy to
answer those questions you can reach me
at leah
mfocus.org
for me the wrap-up is easy um one thing
i found
that works quite well is a company's
motivation to hire
so when a company is motivated to hire
and have them think about contributing
which could be a talk at a community
event or a conference or sponsoring a
conference and that's been a strong
motivator in pirate in london with
larger organizations and get them to
point their wallets towards sponsoring
in some shape or form
and then that tends to work pretty well
and that brings of course uh support
into our community uh where it can be
directed to uh long-term support for the
projects so that'll be my closing note
uh katrina
yeah so um
all of that and i just wanted to do this
that um a couple of things i do want to
mention i was just talking to my team
today about getting involved in projects
and that sometimes people find that
barrier to entry a little bit high and
so one of my big suggestions i always
offer people if they do want to get
involved in projects is to make pull
requests on documentation that is a
really good way to get involved because
there's never enough documentation
on on projects and it's a great way to
get
familiar with a project learn the people
who are on the project and start
becoming a part of the community
and that's a very direct way that people
you know contributors can get involved
and then on top of that i do want to
mention that within companies that a lot
of support you'd be surprised what the
voices of people on teams even you know
independent or individual contributors
within organizations pushing up from the
bottom in order to be able to um effect
change and being able to ask for support
and putting people in touch with the
right people so that we can talk about
you know corporate sponsorships and pi
data sponsorships and all those things
um you know all of the uh
offices that we work with in order to
solicit you know donations these people
change all the time or there might be
some other person we can talk to or
there's another you know division we can
talk to and things like that in order to
help track down these funds and then um
the last thing i do want to mention is
the the need i think for us to
acknowledge that we do need money in our
unrestricted funds
that that was one in particular that i
think that we should be pushing right
now as a community because um this does
go you know it's great to earmark funds
for particular projects fantastic it's
wonderful but then all the other
projects and all the other new
initiatives that we're able to fund and
be able to help grow is really important
so
giving directly to num focus to allow us
to distribute those funds is incredibly
important and would be very much
appreciated any way that you can can
help
and my final comment would be that
giving back to the open source community
participating in um focus
is about being a part of the
conversation this can occur at many
scopes in many scales
it can start with giving money to num
focus or donating staff time to num
focus it can be as small as
participating in an event
helping to volunteer for an event it can
be as small as
telling the projects that you use hey
we're using your tool and it's a great
tool
anything that you can do to be a part of
the conversation to be a part of the
open development of these tools helps
benefit these tools and one way or the
other and it is in your best interest to
be a part of them focus in whatever
fashion you choose
either to help be an industry leader and
to lead the direction of these software
tools for your industry
or
to be able to service your own needs for
these projects by letting the project
know i use your tool i love it but could
you also do this or i use your tool and
i have this little fix could you help me
just make sure that this gets in
whatever the case may be there is a
benefit to be had at whatever scale that
you contribute to the open source
community and it really behooves you to
be a bigger part of this and so if you
are interested in any of these ideas and
getting involved in whatever fashion or
getting more involved please feel free
to reach out to me to katrina to ian or
to leah we'll share our contact details
in the zoom
chat
and conrad hopefully we'll also have an
opportunity to share with the attendees
after the fact any final details we have
but otherwise you can always email
believe it's info numfocus.org to reach
the num focus switchboard or tweet at us
at numfocus on twitter
thanks everyone for joining in i'll hand
it over to conrad to close us up
cool thank you um yeah uh just from like
uh
the current macro perspective uh it's
been increasingly hard to find good
talent across the world it's only going
to be increasingly harder
and so i think it's very important for
companies to
be able to provide their staff with
the ability to
the feeling that they're doing something
meaningful and also
just uh provide them with
uh
the ability to stay let's see to keep
the edge right by by contributing to
um open source projects and and being
the most updated with uh all the neos
open source stuff
um so
um thank you everyone uh for joining
uh
i'm sure we all had like a very
interesting convo um and we'll hope we
hope to see you at the rest of the
conference and i'm going to say thank
you again to conrad because it's 5 a.m
for you
you're doing a crazy good job there out
in hong kong thank you very much for
staying up so late to run these uh these
expert briefing sessions today
and for your work on monday running them
as well it's been a great first
experiment i hope we can repeat to these
for future conferences